multiple players it's your Monday
afternoon dose of crazy couch co-op
competitive games and yelling I'm your
host Chris waters joining us from other
ocean is Frank Shefali special guest
here to talk about my dog that's right
and play I Darb and kick our butts at
night our because he hasn't even told us
how to play I think max will make itto
son I am on the inside track with the
I've dived knowledge I saw this game
back during a GC like a month few weeks
ago and I never that was whatever that
was it's just all blast together
so I played two matches to and I'm
feeling good about my chances excellent
Eric tey what about you I dive newbie
like myself I got some seasoned veterans
on the other end of the couch here
what's this alright you know we're
plucky upstarts you know I think we just
have the tech I don't know starting to
onto but later in the later on we're
gonna balloon it to the full eight
player capacity my god and there will be
a sting of clothes we eight players on
the xbox one is that possible can you
believe it possible I don't know you
brought eight controllers and presumably
there's a reason and it's not mass
deception so I count on it I haven't
seen it yeah okay stay tuned well I'm
gonna tell you guys rule one abide dark
before we start rule one rule one is uh
winners don't use drugs just keep that
in mind folks if you want to use drugs I
need to lose you're good okay throw the
game you take your dogs but if you want
to win okay so you guys want to get
started off the drugs let's do it
alright now I'll tell you a little bit
about the background of the game as we
go so person a you see who you are here
I'm c3 c4 I'm c1 alright - up and down
pick your team we're not doing
okay cool serial killers let me think
sure all right oh how do you switch the
character left and right to switch
characters Tony the Tiger that is a
tiger guy frog all right space bores
nobody do anything I'm gonna tell you
how to play if you have a blue arrow
above your head your goal is to get that
ball into that blue goal yeah red air
above your head the inverse is true a to
jump everybody jumping jumping yeah yeah
jump so Chris you're right trigger for
me pulse move now
if someone has possession of the ball
you knock it out of their hands pulsing
if you have possession of the ball that
same button will shoot the ball now
allow me to demonstrate something really
quick kick I'm gonna actually give you
guys some points typical shot would go
something like this
throw it own goal okay so I just gave
you guys two points I'm sorry that's
really generous um let's see what else
should we start with purple platforms
here yeah you can duck and jump down
through and also jumping up through them
white platforms you can't let's go ahead
and get started
base course does not mess around you
down here captain
so if you guys are interested in team
play as opposed to just running out to
the ball move which is it behold the B
bike draw - site to pass the ball on
that you let go to pass it
okay you don't have the ball you can
kind of say like hey here we go team
alright so but so you face right now
right now you tap B and it's gonna point
at your only teammate yes once once
things get more won four more teammates
on the field
it'll make sense all right cool I
believe you yeah you're taking them off
take them off all right that's the end
of the first quarter for a quarter game
all right
you see these rings rings the one
outside the big rings five points okay
three inside to inside the next one and
then if you walk it in it's one slam
don't get it illegally
kind of like this oh thank you for
letting him show that he gave us those
free points earlier so I guess I was
just nice nice pending our own goal okay
one final move ever nobody move okay
take your right stick here shake it back
and forth really compressing compressing
you're compressing okay you built up
pressure right trigger chaos we're just
guys mind if I hit score 5 points yeah
what's your game we wanna you don't want
you to show it off you know that's why
we're sort of letting ya you know do all
right sir scoring a lot of famous types
of tradition I
pulse as you can see the pulsing
destroys white blocks temporarily also
what hey did I pass a night shoot Oh
oh nice rejection thank you thank you
oh no stop the Admiral why did I steal
it
alright guys press a to cry if you lost
all winning team shake your right stick
I could just cry more would kill the
MVPs I don't think it's gonna happen
that's I don't you know actually I
should say I'd are back calm right now
there's a character creator we have one
in game here too okay Erica Loza but if
you go to Adar calm you can make it
character you draw it spits out a QR
code mm-hmm if we had the Kinect
connected right now I would show you how
that works
oh I'm there just imagine you've drawn
something yes you yes I could see ow oh
it's you have a QR code on your phone so
call it right in the right in the Kinect
get you right in there but cool yeah
mary has consumed Frank Capaldi entirely
and thus ensured that she will live for
another year she's also gave historic
magic three hundred years ago actually
we've got another couch now delicious
alright so as you see we got we're on
the winners couch right now if we want
to go back over to lose your couch loser
couch down there and the crackers would
even win do not even all cramming on the
same couch alright everybody on the
so-called winners couch press the left
trigger everyone on the other coast
right here alright
let's go anywhere okay okay all right
I'm play defense ready brush to the
snapper I'm gonna try to not get it in
our whoever's playing Tim Schafer's
played this that's me now we're foes
those children he went there
yeah apparently I will be jam solo you
get we can see you can do it somebody
just get up there somebody get up there
red rabbit walking in solo show there
you go oh I got this right it would have
been good
Oh go score Jim shoot it from the long
Sun net we got to score first story
all right uh I think that now that we've
reached the pinnacle bide our play which
is to say total bunny victory ah Frank
why are we playing this eight players on
an Xbox 360 I don't know where you found
eight Xbox 360 Xbox one Spock's one I'm
just so caught up I know are you asking
where we found a controller yeah those
are the Best Buy in Emeryville
California sweet when is this a game
that people can play on their Xbox ones
this is a game that eventually people
will be able to play on Xbox one we're
aiming for this fall think about this
game though is that it's really early
and we're still taking suggestions we're
tweaking it as we go so go to I'd Darb
calm there's a little suggestion box if
you've watched the game now I'm sure you
have some really dumb ideas for us so
let's have them as you can see they're
very amenable to those yes well also you
can draw your own character you save it
right on that website there's a gallery
there's all sorts of stuff only two
people have drawn male genitalia so far
was that over so it's just going against
my theory that if you give someone a
drunk team built drug so we can head
over there draw of the multiple players
cast and get ourselves a team in eidart
yeah and then maybe it'll make in the
final game but yeah hopefully for this
no one will ever choose it because it's
not cool Bayer Xbox one probably steam
we're thinking about early access
because we want to get this in hands so
that people can play it and give
suggestions so yeah that's lighter
thanks sweet thank you Frank for coming
on thank all you guys for playing and I
want to give special thanks here and
seem rabid the glorious victory buddy
fantastic thanks to all you folks for
watching multiple players see you
tomorrow at 11 a.m. for the Shawn method
and then at 2 for the lobby
ok we're doing this by somebody help see
you guys